[Applause]
the morning all these our line the
reason for this this morning session we
all feel obviously that of all of this
most amazing century that into whose
last decade we are now moving and will
be reviewing in this next 10 years as we
come to the actual turn of centuries the
most turbulent decade of them all
perhaps the most seminal of them all the
one that undoubtedly has affected the
future of the United States and the
world and for how long which is our
question was the 60s and that's what
we're going to look at this morning with
some distinguished panelists
distinguished journalists to engage them
in dialogue after they have made their
opening statements that we have asked
them to limit their statements to 10
minutes apiece we all know from our own
experience at various lecterns that
we're all inclined to run over that
occasionally we're going to try to
prevent that I'm going to be a very
strong hand I'm going to come up here
and throw my arm around them and then I
hit ten minutes and slowly drag them
back to their seats I hope with the
amount of dignity that whatever we can
muster at that point our first speaker
is Robert Moses a lecture activist
author teacher and by the way I'm
introducing you people to our speakers
today although most of you know them if
not personally certainly by reputation
but a little review wouldn't help in
case there are any cub editors here will
haven't to read their own papers lately
the Moses wrote Robert Moses rose to
prominence in 1960s when he headed the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee became known in those days as
snick which as you all know pioneered
civil rights in a hundred small southern
communities and indeed across the nation
a New York Times Book Review by Howell
Raines calls him the legendary SNCC
leader who are
is the freedom summer of 1984 and a 1964
excuse me
an absolutely apt description of course
his soaring voice is remembered by
marchers as he asked time after time
when there is no justice what is the
state but a rubber band enlarged Robert
Moses thanks Walter thanks everybody
what I would like to do in my 10 minutes
is try to frame a problem which I think
is a problem that's going to be pressing
in us in the 90s and try to relate that
to a couple of themes of the 60s one
theme of citizenship on the one hand and
the other theme of empowerment the
problem is a problem which you might
think of as mundane it's the problem of
mathematics and more specifically the
problem of algebra and making giving
access to algebra to all of our middle
school students in the inner cities of
this country it's a problem that I'm
working on we have a project which we
call the algebra project and we are
working it in it started in Cambridge
and it's moved into Boston schools and
in some schools in Atlanta and we're
about to approach cities around the
country
San Diego Oakland Baltimore Louisville
and Milwaukee to see if they are
interested in working with us on this
problem and what I'd like to do is state
why I think this is a central problem
which faces us as a country and
particularly faces black people and to
try to frame its relationship to the 60s
you can think of it as a problem of
mathematics literacy and think of it as
a problem of forming an appropriate
standard for literacy
for the coming century in mathematics
and one way of getting a handle on it is
to think about the contrast between the
revolution which has shaped the life
that we grew up in the Industrial
Revolution and the one which is shaping
the lives of the younger generation
today the computer revolution the
Industrial Revolution as you know came
in as a way of mechanizing physical
labor and what it did was provide a way
to handle with machines sort of routine
physical tasks the computer revolution
as you know which we are going through
now is a way of computerizing
algorithmic thought processes and what
it does is provide a way of handling
with computers any kind of step-by-step
mental process now what's happening
there with these two revolutions is that
the Industrial Revolution on the one
hand brought in a standard of literacy
which we evolved familiar with reading
and writing it is in order to take place
or take your position as a citizen in
the in the arrangements political
arrangements and economic arrangements
which came out of the Industrial
Revolution you had to read in life and
we are all familiar with that we've been
through that what's happening with us
now with the new revolution is that
there is now being put in place a new
requirement for literacy for citizenship
and that's a mathematics and scientific
sort of requirement and what we don't
quite grasp in our consciousness is that
this new math and literacy requirement
is going to impact on who is and who
won't be a citizen that is just as the
reading and writing formed a line
in the society and those who on one side
were really but able to participate in
it as a citizen in the arrangements math
and science is going to increasingly
play that role in the 21st century and
people who don't have a minimum math and
science literacy will not be able to
participate in the economic arrangements
and the political arrangements which are
evolving under our noses
through the new technology now this
problem particularly impacts on the
inner cities and on the problems of the
young people in the inner cities who are
caught up in the drugs and the war and
drugs and and the violence which is
imploding in the black communities all
across this country and one of the
things that has to be done if we are not
going to have a generation of people who
function really as serfs in our inner
cities just as the people that we worked
with in the 60s on the plantations of
Mississippi were serfs in the society
then serfs in the sense that they lacked
the fundamental literacy requirements to
participate in the economic arrangements
that they were part of even in that
sharecropping system the inner city
young people are facing that same
dilemma and we are raising if you like
nurturing if you like within our inner
cities in our present arrangements a new
society of serves people who are unable
to participate in the underlying
economic and political arrangements
which are evolving in our society around
these this new technology and it seems
to me that the
is a problem which newspaper editors
could begin to inform themselves about
and begin to understand and understand
how the voting effort which we took
place in the 60s and which was centered
around the question of empowerment
particularly empowering black people so
that they could have participate in the
political arrangements has now a new
dimension there is this question now of
empowerment which has to be focused also
on education and on young people in on
setting a standard which will allow
people to participate in the current
economic arrangements and political
arrangements which are flowing out of
this new technology and strangers and
they seem algebra in the middle school
years provides one approach to handling
this problem and in a nutshell we use
algebra in our school systems wrongly we
use it as a standard for excluding
students schools have a problem of
sorting students but there's nothing
that says that algebra has to be the
instrument to sort them and what we do
currently is we use algebra in the
middle school years as a way of sorting
students we no longer can afford to do
that it's possible to introduce and
teach all in a school young students
algebra that's what we're doing in our
program there's a curriculum that we've
developed which allows young students to
do this so there's a political question
about the use of algebra in the school
system there has to be a political
decision by school superintendents by
school principals you have to
participate in that political decision
namely to use algebra as a meaningful
means of establishing a floor under
every middle school student so that they
can go into the high school ready to do
the math sequence there and the point
here is not an arrow point about
education but a broad point about who
are going to be the citizens in the 21st
century in our society who are going to
be the people who can participate in the
coming economic and political
Arrangements Somozas I certainly think
you're addressing the right crowd with
that lesson I've always believed that
the career choice being a journalist is
made by those who fail algebra
gloria steinem we all know writer-editor
lecture feminist course co-founder in
1972 of MS magazine the national
feminist monthly her books outrageous
and everyday rebellions Maryland Norma
Jean and currently shortly on your in
your book stalls the bedside book of
self-esteem little brown the publisher
co-founder MS foundation for women the
only national multiracial public woman's
fund and told National Women's Political
caucus voters for choice women's Action
Alliance coalition of labor union women
she served as a political columnist for
New York magazine in 1968 72 I'm proud
to say she made a couple of
contributions to the CBS Evening News
while I was had something to do with it
not nearly enough contributions Gloria
it's your turn
first I'd like to thank this
organization for helping us to translate
the 60s into the 70s and the 80s by
making the leadership look a little bit
more like the readership with your job
fairs and your consultant programs
actually that's al Neuharth sprays
sounds more like Dick Gregory doesn't
and as as one of very many people who've
been pressing you it seems only right to
say thank you because we have so much
more to ask I'd like to try to place us
in history a little bit and then we
didn't discuss a story or two about the
state of the movement currently that I
think we're very much missing certainly
is appropriate that I follow Bob because
clearly the the women's movement was
born of the peace movement and the civil
rights movements of the 60s and in my
own personal life that took the form of
and indeed all movements are born
personally of interviewing fannie lou
hamer and discovering that she had been
sterilized without her knowledge and
against her will in a hospital in her
hometown and there was no place for her
no forum for her to redress this
enormous grievance and the other great
experience was going to a hearing in New
York City in about 1969 I think which
was an alternate hearing to one held by
the state legislature on the
liberalisation of the New York State
abortion law because the New York State
Legislature had asked 14 men and one nun
to testify a group of early feminists
decided to have their own speak out and
I went as a reporter for New York
Magazine to cover this and for the first
time in my life I heard women stand up
and tell the truth about their lives in
public and it was those kinds of
experiences which made us understand
that there had to be an autonomous and
the pendant movement based on gender for
women of all races all ages all classes
that there were kinds of issues here
that went very deep now clearly the the
fact that race and sex movements have
always gone together the suffragists and
abolitionist movements clearly did means
that they historically anthropologically
go together but because we had not been
educated to understand this we had to
rediscover the wheel all over again
however I would like to make a plea that
we think in centuries instead of decades
because it is the the the one or two
year thinking the decade kind of
thinking that makes us use phrases like
post feminism which is a lot like saying
post democracy and what we are talking
about here is trying to humanize or
overthrow you can pick your verb
depending on the state of your patience
today the caste systems based on race
and based on race and based on sex which
are many thousands of years old and
these movements therefore are at least
100 hundred and fifty years by all
historical precedent and clearly even in
this young country we have had to the
first wave which gained a legal identity
as human beings for women of all races
and men of color and the second wave
which struggles to gain a legal and
social equality but we must remember I
think the length of the struggle
therefore I suggest you that really what
we have completed is mainly the first
stage of the second wave and that is
mainly a consciousness-raising stage
because now there is no one in the
country who doesn't feel differently
about the issues of equality and all of
the issues have majority support in all
of the public opinion told it's not so
easy to tell that necessarily when you
look at the stories like Time magazine's
cover story and news week's cover story
and so on you have to read the poll to
find out what's really going on the
stories don't always resemble the polls
but nonetheless these issues do have an
enormous majority support that but we
have just begun the second stage of this
second way which is to change the
institutions of our lives
to make these new dreams possible what
do I mean by that well we've made the
revolutionary discovery that children
have to parents I don't know why it took
us so long but we don't have childcare
we don't have parental leave for fathers
we don't have changed work patterns
that's what I mean we have a new idea
but we haven't changed our structure we
have named problems we now have words
like battered women displaced homemakers
sexual harassment and so on 10 or 15
years ago those things were just called
life I mean there was no word for them
but now we have words for them but we
have really not begun to to solve them
of course with this majority change has
also come a backlash because now those
folks who used to be the in the majority
feel endangered and no matter how much
we tell them that we're talking about
choice here since many of them are
trained in authoritarian ways to believe
there's only one way to live they feel
threatened and therefore we find
ourselves in interesting times we have I
think it's a it'sh curse isn't it may
you live in interesting times we have
raised hopes and ideals we have a
reality that has only just barely begun
to budge and we have a backlash so
looking to the future to the translation
of the issues of the late 60s and 70s in
terms of the women's movement to the 90s
I have identified five areas arbitrarily
because whenever I was sitting in an
audience I and somebody said there are
five major points here I always said oh
thank God there were five points but you
can divide these any other way you like
I would say that the the first one
clearly and as you can see by the
awakening experiences of the women's
movement that I just quoted to you is
there's a reason for this and it's true
all over the world and that is that the
first issue is reproductive freedom is
establishing reproductive freedom as a
basic human right like freedom of speech
freedom of
sembly the power of the state stops at
our skin this is how we got in the
trouble we are as females from being
controlled is the most basic means of
production the means of reproduction and
declaring reproductive freedom and our
rights to control our own physical
selves is the primary issue for women
all over the world the democratization
of families I don't know you know and
remember how in political science
classes they used to say to us the
family is the microcosm of the state so
how come they never figured out that you
can't have a democracy unless you have a
democratic family you can't have a
hierarchical family you can't have the
son getting the education money and so
on you have to have a democratic family
the democratization of work which means
for women first and foremost ending the
semantic slavery of the phrase women who
don't work homemakers work longer and
harder than any other class of worker in
the United States for less pay for no
well more likelihood of being replaced
by a younger worker I mean we could go
on with them and in third-world
countries it's it's exactly the same
problem women who produce most or all of
the food their families eat in the
fields and so on are called women who
don't work they're not counted in the
gross national product together we're
trying to end this semantic slavery by
defining all work as work and the second
part of that is to revalue work that is
to say that it's going to be valued by
the importance of the of the job to the
community and not by the sex of the race
of the worker which is as we know now
how jobs are valued in fact by the sex
or race of the worker for the most part
if forth is is a democratizing culture
by that I just mean the you know all of
the sea we swim in every day although
sometimes I think what happens to men is
called politics what happens to women is
called culture so that they say you
can't change that that's culture but
nonetheless it's what we see on
television what we read in our
newspapers for who edits our newspapers
and so on it's all of that including
religion and who we see represented as
deities
and what they look like and how come God
so often looks like the ruling class and
so on and all the ways that we are
trying to democratize culture and
finally there's access and that has to
do with all of these issues in a sense
because it's can we vote can we find the
caucus where the secret decisions are
being made can we get into the to the
old boys network and so on it's access
in every area I think in the there
probably is the place where the women's
movement has done the least well because
we have not yet learned how to turn out
our vote properly and that if I were to
name any disappointment of the past
years that would be yet we have waited
for the media to turn out our vote and
that isn't going to happen we have to do
it ourselves in the old-fashioned way
block by block women are psychic
immigrants but we have not yet learned
how to turn out our vote in the way that
immigrant groups have done so where are
we going now well I think it's you know
sort of blowing in the wind we're in
that in-between stage when when you know
that you when you hear spokeswoman or
spokesperson you know that's a woman and
when you hear but a man is still a man
you know women are people but men are
still men I think that's sort of where
we are we still are in the stage where
reporter will come into a women's group
which for instance in the case of a
literal meeting of the National Women's
Political caucus is the only racially
economically ethnically representative
group I've ever seen and still was
reported as a white middle class group
and I therefore as the I see my friend
approaching will save my story ideas for
you but I have some because like Bob I'm
an organizer and specificity is
everything thank you
[Applause]
general Westmoreland was born in South
Carolina 1914 West Point and Harvard
Business School 17 battle stars when his
ribbons and 17 battle campaigns in three
wars for distinguished service medals
decorated by 16 foreign nations he's
commanded every size military element
from a platoon to his job as chief of
staff of the United States Army he
commanded of course we all know US
troops in Vietnam by the South Vietnam
military for over four years
he was Time Magazine's Man of the Year
in 1965 we're honored to have you with
us general
I have an incentive to move this along
because I don't want to be embraced by
Walter
[Laughter]
the political fallout of the war in
Vietnam some of which is now unfinished
business is widespread in my opinion and
from my perspective three areas seem to
be important first the volunteer army
and the implications of the
discontinuance of Selective Service the
military draft secondly the distortion
of the Vietnam War in the public's mind
and finally the now forgotten
short-lived ideology of the 1960's over
the years United States Army has fought
our nation's battles and final analysis
the United States military that has
apparently at last been a party to
making the world safe for democracy
between the wars the Army has been a de
facto social force it has given a sense
of discipline and opportunity the young
men made stagnant by the environment in
which they were born during the Great
Depression of the 1920s and 30s the army
carried the Civilian Conservation Corps
the CCC many if not most of the
individuals were well served by this
program
which resulted from their being given
skills and opportunities that did not
exist before Selective Service namely
the draft ended in 1973 the follow-on
volunteer Army has been a success we now
have perhaps the best army in our
history and probably the best in the
world today
it has limited use for unskilled persons
and there are only a few within the
ranks of the military today meanwhile
within our society
we're plagued with stagnant young men
and the so called ghettos of our large
cities and in the rural areas thousands
of young men are unemployed and in many
cases encouraged by their environment
resort to crime perhaps the time has
arrived for us to consider another type
program similar to that of the CCC
I would call it the jobs program the
timing of such a program would be
fortuitous since the military is being
reduced and the thousands of capable
trained motivated and reliable men being
discharged from the military against
their desires and will be looking for an
employment they will be looking for
another challenge and during that
timeframe some military bases will be
closed ideal locations and facilities
for such a program that I propose a jobs
program now my second point no war in
history has been those so distorted in
the public mind as the war in Vietnam
such a situation was a byproduct of what
is news or entertainment news
entertainment is not the run of the mill
it is the offbeat or the sensational
which makes the headlines or a puppet TV
program our national political objective
in Vietnam was not to conquer North
Vietnam but to defeat aggression from
the communist north and by our bombing
of North Vietnam to against military
targets always insisted upon by our
military leadership to raise the cost of
the aggression of the Communists and
hopefully to bring about a settlement
of the war as we did in Korea a
settlement at the conference table now
we've missed the opportunity after the
defeat of the enemy's Tet Offensive in
early 1968 by not using our air power
against North Vietnam as was done in
late 1972 and 73 unfortunately after our
troops had been withdrawn and our
bargaining power had been reduced the
latest blow to the understanding of the
war or movies which explored the
sensational and bash the veteran this is
disturbing to that Vietnam veteran who
gave it his all and carrying on a
national policy and showbiz has taken
over the making of history for the
masses it is a low blow to the thousands
of law-abiding dedicated Americans who
answered President Kennedy's clarion
call will pay any price bear any burden
to assure the survival and the success
of Liberty it is time to give the
Vietnam veterans a break and the public
and accurate balanced account of their
performance and to override the National
mindset that seemed to prevail the facts
are that when the North Vietnamese Army
invaded in masse South Vietnam in 1975
American combat troops had not been on
the battlefield for approximately three
years and the Congress had withdrawn
from Vietnam our support both physical
and moral support sadly our nation
abandoned
South Vietnam when American troops were
withdrawn the Communist enemy himself in
the south had been defeated and our
troops had not lost the battle in the
south of major significance so one has
to ask the question what has North
Vietnam won from this traumatic
experience the Vietnamese Vietnamese
communists have made a mess of things
thousands of Vietnamese have escaped and
continued to do so and in the process a
communist protocol economic system has
been discredited many thousands of
Vietnamese are now good and successful
citizens in our nation and other
countries of the free world the
Vietnamese Army has been fighting the
Chinese along its southern border
blocking Chinese advances ironically one
of our strategic objectives meanwhile we
brought ten years of safety for what is
now known as ASEAN the Association of
Southeast Asian Nations for the five
countries comprising that coalition in
Southeast Asia namely Thailand Malaysia
Singapore Philippines and Indonesia all
but Thailand had been colonized Western
nations those ten years were needed for
those insecure countries to mature to
stand on their own and to develop
self-confidence they had been threatened
by a dynamic communist movement during
the 60s they are now those are Zeon
countries strategically important to us
because of their rich natural resources
oil important minerals raw rubber and
timber and particularly the fact that
they control the very few narrow
waterways through the South Pacific to
the Indian Ocean and mints to the Middle
East the final assessment of our
commitment in Southeast Asia is that our
strategic objectives have been met and
we have no troops in the area as we now
have in Korea to maintain the status quo
Vietnam is a threat to no one it has no
true friends and it has been an
embarrassment to the Communist world
to my final point it seems to me then we
as a people in as a nation again feel
insecure not by the threat of the
hostile nation but by the loss of our
forgotten ideale
ideological zeal which we need to
sustain us perhaps it is time for our
leaders and our people to emphasize
idealism to return to the short-lived
theme of the early 1960s that's not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country
yes there is
unfinished business
settle I want to thank you so much for
staying here 10 minutes I can't imagine
anything worse than my having to come up
here and ask you to leave the stand
father Hesburgh we all also know
president emeritus of Notre Dame the end
of the large longest tenure among CEOs
of major universities in 1987 35 years
even president since 1952 in retirement
he's developing to knock podium
Institute's that he was instrumental in
founding Institute for International
Peace Studies and the Kellogg Institute
for International Studies he was a
charter member the u.s. Commission on
civil rights he chaired that important
body from 1969 to 1972 and when I
believe President Nixon replaced him
father Hesburgh
[Applause]
speaking of algebra Robert I had to get
tutored on Sunday to pass and I almost
didn't then I'm glad you're doing
something about that now for someone in
my position to look back on the student
Revolution has really got to be mezzo
kist ik I have scars to prove that I
went through it and lost most of my
friends in the process my fellow
presidents it came up like spontaneous
combustion it was like summer lightning
against the dark afternoon summer sky
suddenly it was there we saw a picture
of a beginning of this program Mario
Savio and free speech at Berkeley from
there it jumped from peak to peak
it went from Berkeley to Columbia where
students went into Grayson Kirk's office
and drank a sherry smoked his cigars and
unfortunately crept on his rug but that
was symbolic of the attitude of the
times Tori's college presidents and then
went to Chicago where a group really
took over the president's office for 12
days then to Harvard that great bastion
of learning a great Peak which was
almost brought down in a few days that
its headquarters was being invaded I
think ultimately it struck everywhere it
certainly struck the university I was
living in at the time and it probably
reached its peak or its nadar depending
how you look at it at Kent State I think
speaking to editors having said when in
the early 60s when all this or late 60s
and this began to happen I have to say
something about who and why and what and
where and how the obvious victims I
think looking back on and perhaps on
prejudice were the university presidents
we used to meet a group of us with South
American and Central American presidents
of universities a thing called cheer the
conference on higher education in the
the university world of America and we
used to chide them for all of their
strikes and all their revolutions and
the fact they couldn't get on with
education suddenly and without any
warning it struck us and it really
struck the people in charge who were the
university presidents all they could do
is improvise and improvisation didn't
work very well I remember a short period
of time during which Jim Percocet
Cornell was let go because he didn't
call the police and they tuesday at
harvard call the police and he was let
go to it began of course with Clark Kerr
and I think a nadir and that particular
line of succession was Courtney Smith at
Swarthmore who died after a serious
confrontation with his students it was
an unhappy period at best and I don't
think the people who suffered or were
drawn under by it were bad people I
found them very good people but as I say
they were in proposition people the only
path to go why did it all happen I think
it happened because the younger
generation simply disagreed with the
older generation about a fairly good
number of social issues I think one
could say quite honestly looking back on
it it was probably the first time in the
history of this country where the
younger generation actually educated the
older generation and came up with some
process of success in that the what they
were upset about was of course the
Vietnam War perhaps because they were on
the list to be drafted they were upset
about the slow progress and civil rights
they were upset about poverty in the
richest country on earth and the fact
that people weren't taking any of these
problems all that seriously at least
they didn't think the adults were
they're also upset frankly about the
education they're receiving I like to
think they were wrong in this because
they thought it was irrelevant and I
think nothing is so irrelevant tomorrow
as what is relevant today
by reading yesterday's newspaper if you
want to prove that out what really
happened was they when they got started
in education the curriculum was really -
based by a lot of so-called relevant
courses most of which are now gone the
requirements that forever were thought
important like history in education were
dropped grades were inflated voluntarily
by faculty who didn't want these
students to drop out of school and then
be drafted and have to go to Vietnam I
think a fact that most people missed was
that less than 2% of all the service
people in Vietnam had college degrees
less than 2% they're mostly young
officers have went through the ROTC how
did all of it happened well it happened
by violence there was a new word
thrashing and there was burning I
remember one day when an academic
building was burning north of us at
Michigan State west of us at at
Northwestern and they were talking about
burning the ROTC on our campus
fortunately they decided not to
curiously this revolution died as
quickly as it began I said earlier began
as like summer lightning and there's no
real knowledge to this day I think why
it suddenly stopped certainly everything
didn't get better all of a sudden I had
talked to President Nixon though within
two weeks of his inauguration I told him
two things I thought he should do right
away one was to put in an all voluntary
army and get rid of the draft and
secondly get the vote for 18 years old
18 year old students who could be
drafted therefore ought to be able to
vote for their leadership he did both of
those things I think was very little
credit there was a book written many of
you probably read by Charles Reich
called the greening of America
it sounded like great prophecy when I
read it and yet within a year of the
dying down of the student Revolution it
was gone finished over what was the
effect of all this I think when the
student revolution stops suddenly we
inherited a new generation of students
who were if anything ultra conservative
and very quiet the quietness was
welcomed for a time
I think the ultra-conservative nature of
that student body was not a good thing
for this country I like to think that
one can be both conservative and liberal
I'm conservative about values but
extremely liberal about how those values
have to be achieved it's not easy to
achieve values in a country that's very
gated but in any event they came back
conservative in the early 70s some of
the bohemian ism that came in bohemian
ism and language and dress and style
music and drugs some of that continued
but I think most of it is is going it's
not gone curiously the students showed
great responsibility when they found out
that drugs had genetic effects and they
were thinking of their children and
suddenly drugs were not very popular
especially psychedelic drugs there was a
lot of backtracking going on today to
recover back into the curriculum the
things that were lost Allan bloom of the
universe Chicago came out with a book on
the losing of values in American
education a couple of years ago and sold
a million copies I'm not sure that many
people read them but in any event he did
sell the books because it was a popular
subject the good news is I think that
students today are more than ever before
engaged in service engaged in helping
those less fortunate engaged in really
thinking long thoughts about the civil
rights revolution the feminist
revolution the all the revolutions that
make sense I'm happy to say that we went
co-educational waited at the end of the
student Revolution and the school I grew
up in which was pretty male chauvinist
became a much better place overnight
because we now have 5050 men and women I
think the concept of service today which
at least a third of our students are
engaged in to the tune of 5 to 20 hours
a week voluntarily with youngsters with
minority youngsters that need to be
tutored with big brother big sister
helping old people something we have
this week called Christmas in April
where they go out and clean up the yards
in the homes of all the old people who
can't do it for themselves these are
good
signs I think America needs service it
needs young people with ideals it needs
some of the enthusiasm that we had
during the student revolution I often
thought that a perfect world would have
the enthusiasm of the young and the
student revolution joined to that great
idealism that has made this country
great and has made our social agenda
important for all of us thank you very
much
[Applause]
John Erlichman graduated from Stanford
and UCLA UCLA for political science
graduate law degree at Stanford trial
work in Seattle from 52 to 69 it was an
advance man for Richard Nixon became a
counsel to the President to 1969 an
assistant to the president in 1970 and
73 as we all learn involved in 73 to 77
and mostly recalling those days in
various hearings trials and
investigations and as we know he served
some eighteen months in federal prison
camp
Stafford Arizona for some of the events
of those times from 1975 to the present
he's been a full time writer and a very
successful one and very entertaining and
provocative one he did daily radio
commentary for Mutual weekly TV
commentary and SATA Fe New Mexico where
he lives his books include witness to
power a china card the company the Rigby
file fiction essay and Parade magazine
in this month in April on his visit to
the Soviet Union he's at work now on
another novel he's married father six
children and we're delighted to have
John Ehrlichman with us today
[Applause]
good morning those of you by the door
their seats over here unless you want to
be on the escape route and I feel for
you standing through all of this good
heavens
unfinished business I thought what I
would do is spend a few minutes with
psychohistory
for which I have very little use a few
minutes talking about the environment
and then give you one story idea
I lost Steinem the psychohistory it
seems to me is is begun by this film
that we saw at the beginning but the
flavor really doesn't come through that
we're looking at the 60s but in in
practical effect the 60s span what 15
maybe 16 years and it was a time of
incredible inhumanity a lot of violence
I can I can recall I was involved in
some campaigns through the 60s and I
don't you all remember but those were
campaigns in which the presidential
candidates were heckled they were
interrupted they were driven off stage
they were pelted with rocks and eggs and
not just Richard Nixon but Hubert
Humphrey as well it was a it was a time
when the civil rights movement involved
great violence the campus protests we
had bombings we had free terrible
assassinations during that period of
time it was a time of terrific national
psychosis and I suggest to you that as a
result of all of that and these were at
a time of the intertwining --zz of the
various movements that have been talked
about here this morning we had violent
demonstrations on the on the subject of
civil rights we had violent
demonstrations on account of the war
it was a it was a very very tough time
to be involved in politics to be
involved for that matter in in ordinary
society and I dare say good many of you
covered one or more of those violent
events a great many people were given
great expectations by the politicians
during that period of time and as we
came out of the 60s there was a
recession there was a drying up of those
expectations and some great
disappointment there was also a loss of
political capacity on the part of some
of those people who espouse these
various movements and I think we have to
notice that I think it explains a lot
about why things happen in the way that
they did it also to me explains why a
great many people it's kind of dropped
out of the political process and turned
to problems that they felt were more
manageable in their personal lives led
by the writings of people like Rachel
Carson and Paul Ehrlich and others they
became persuaded that they might be able
to solve an immediate controllable
worthwhile problem in their own backyard
that is to say to take care of their own
environment in the environment of their
neighborhood the environment of their
community and I got very much caught up
in that in the 60s because I was
practicing law and and got to
specializing and what now has been
stylish Lee termed environmental law in
those days we thought we were dealing
with land-use problems and permit
problems and potential pollution by oil
companies and things at that time on a
kind of ad-hoc basis we didn't realize
we were environmental lawyers but I saw
it at very close hand this kind of
inward-looking on the part of many many
people who became concerned about the
well-being of their own neighborhoods
and they didn't conceive of this as some
kind of a
of a national or a cosmic movement but
simply something that they could have a
voice in and and see themselves being
affected on a local basis and so it was
I think that the environmental movement
so-called began to stitch itself
together in bits and pieces around the
country and people saw that this was
important that they could have a voice
in it that it didn't involve all this
external national neurosis that we were
going through and that it was important
to do and so starting in probably the
late 50s and on through the 60s and on a
very grassroots basis the environmental
movement began interestingly enough and
looking back and checking at Hubert
Humphrey in the campaign of 1968 gave
one speech on the environment that
lasted about 12 minutes Richard Nixon
gave one speech on the environment that
lasted about five minutes and that was
all the presidential leadership there
was right up to 1968 well we got to this
town in 1969 there were two bills
pending in the Senate on the subject of
the environment one espoused by muskie
and the other by Henry Jackson and and
they conflicted because one was a
chairman of a committee the other was a
chairman of another committee and they
were vying for jurisdiction over this
subject we sided with Henry Jackson
because he was right on a BM and some
other things and of a great favorite of
Richard Nixon's and so it was that the
Environmental Protection Agency the
Environmental Protection Act of 1969 was
adopted and we got into the
environmental business and pulled that
subject into the government you all are
terribly fond of anniversaries I know
and those of you who have my phone
number call me whenever there is an
anniversary of anything though first
washing of the windows at the White
House the 200th anniversary of George
Washington getting a
a pair of teeth anything of that sort
and you all call for comment
I think that's laudable I think that
shows I show it shows real ingenuity on
the part of the American professional of
journalism and I commend you for it in
any event this this happens to be the
anniversary of Earth Day and Earth Day
was perhaps one of the one of the key
occurrences in this whole environmental
movement because it took the
neighborhood environmental movement
public and it kind of institutionalized
it in the eyes of great many people in
the country who had not noticed it
previously here's a story idea for you
I'm going to get off here now and having
provoked you a little bit and see what
the questions are a story idea do you
know how much land the federal
government owns in your area check it
out we discovered there was a no
inventory of federal ownership of land
and so we undertook one about 1970 the
fact is the federal government uses its
real estate very very badly and you
could get a five-part series out of that
without getting out of bed there we
started this business of inventory alone
ership and trying to determine whether
we couldn't find a better use for the
federal land and we moved quite a lot of
it into state and local control and off
the off the federal property rolls and
under the tax rolls I think there's room
for tremendous amount of good to be done
by furthering that exercise federal
government owns way too much real estate
what it has it doesn't use very well so
you might look into that you might even
extend it to the state or to the
locality or to some of your public
utilities to see whether the stewardship
of real estate in this country is really
being properly exercised by public
officials I think you'll find that it is
not I give that to you
gratuitous ly I look forward to the
questions and comments I think this is
supposed to be the decade of the
environment the paradox is that the
people who started this thing is a very
simple uncomplicated
have seen it grow into an enormous ly
expensive enormous Li complex problem of
international scope the environment is a
is still a wedge a countercultural wedge
and there's perhaps no active Congress
more countercultural
than this clean air bill that passed the
Senate yesterday it is going to make
profound differences in our culture the
the I've just been to the Soviet Union
as Walter said and it's a wedge there to
it is it is perhaps the most fundamental
test of perestroika that one is going to
see in the Soviet Union the struggle
between the local environmental
committees that are trying to clean
things up and the powerful ministries in
in the Moscow who have a vested interest
in pollution well enough enough of that
[Applause]
meaning absolutely no disrespect
I'm doing reborn the oppressed our
panelists here most of you also know but
I shall do a fast introduction write
down that the group of Jack Nelson you
know most W Washington bureau chief for
Los Angeles Times since 1975 Nieman
Fellow at Harvard Pulitzer Prize winner
for his articles exposing irregularities
at the world's largest mental
institution that's any place in
Washington but he specialized on
Milledgeville Georgia 1960 Jessica
Mitford well James Walt has described
Jessica and a Washington Post article as
an older more even-tempered better read
Jane Fonda she's best known to American
readers through seven books including
the American Way of death kind and
unusual and usual punishment the
American prison business and poisoned
penmanship the general art of muckraking
she's a well born Britain somewhat
acerbic at times I understand outspoken
as she outlines her American career this
way 1936 to 1940 odd jobs such as
marketing researcher bartenders
assistant retail clerk and what I like
about that is her modesty identifying
herself as a bartender's assistant none
of us would ever do that we just simply
say we're bartender World War two office
of Price Administration 1949 to 56
Secretary of Eastbay Civil Rights
Congress and from 56 to the present a
most distinguished writer she lives in
Oakland California with her husband Bob
Dave gergan he's editor of large US News
and World Report he attended both Yale
and Harvard Yale for undergraduate
studies Harvard Law School London
observer called him Washington's lead
insider journalist he teams with mark
shields as a regular analyst on the
macneil-lehrer report regular on
National Public Radio's all things
considered an excellent program before
entering journalism in the mid-80s in
1980s gergan worked for eight years in
the White House under three presidents
most recently as Reagan's White House
communications director 81 84
Dick Gregory glad to have with a social
satirist author lecturer entrepreneur he
gained fame as a comedian the only thing
that I find wrong with the career after
that was that we lost a lot of attention
he gave the comedy which we needed he
was so good at it his participation in
civil rights movement in 1960s led to
efforts toward world peace
hunger American Indian rights
particularly jailed for his part in
various demonstrations and he went on as
we all know hunger strikes to make his
point than he made them well nine books
including dick Gregory's natural diet
for folks who eat and Charlayne
hunter-gault gulped new york-based
national correspondent for the
macneil-lehrer report Newshour
she was talk of the town reporter for
New Yorker magazine she joined the
investigative team at WRC TV here in
Washington and anchored their local
Evening News to the great discomfiture
of those of us at CBS and ABC our
opponents to New York Times in 1968 as
metro reporter she joined macneil-lehrer
in 1978 two recent Emmy Awards for
national news at some Ranade invasion
and her documentary and son of Admiral
Elmo Zumwalt and Agent Orange
that's our panel and I want to remind
the panel and all of you who were our
guest speakers that this is a perfectly
informal conversation for the
enlightenment and amusement perhaps of
our audience and you're welcome to enter
in at any time I will
interpose myself as little as possible
and you want well I'd like to ask the
first question of Robert Moses but as
someone who covered the civil rights
movement I'd like to first make a
comment on what John Ehrlichman said
about violence of civil rights
demonstrations there was very little
violence and civil rights demonstrations
but there was a lot of violence against
the civil rights demonstrations and
anybody who was part of it or who
covered it could tell you that but I
would like to ask Robert Moses I noticed
in the opening film here about the
unfinished business of the 60s it almost
skipped over the civil rights movement
which I really felt dominated the 60s
except for the assassination of Martin
Luther King and right now I mean we're
in the nation's capital probably the
most segregated city in in the United
States despite the fact that we've had
all of the civil rights legislation of
the 1960s I just wanted it if you have
any real optimism about any movement at
all in the form of civil rights today if
there's a my wired up you hear me
there they were to civil rights movement
I think and I think when the Earthmen
was commenting about the violence he was
commenting on the second movement which
was the movement which we call the
rebellion which happened in the inner
cities around the country so would you
call those rights or civil rights
movement I think of them as part of the
movement the expression of black people
to try to to gain their right in this
country right so basically I think of
them as an expression of national I
think that we've got to come to grips
with nationalism as a fourth right
around the world right and it's
expression within this country right we
see it now and we applaud it in Eastern
Europe we don't applaud it when it
happens at our doorstep right and one of
the the ways in which the movement of
black people expressed itself in the 60s
one of its nationalist expressions was
through the rebellion one of the
difficulties in this country I think is
that what we don't have is a an
acceptable political expression of
nationalism on the part of of black
people that is black people have not
figured out an appropriate strategy to
express their nationalism which will
actually which actually worked and will
take hold and that violence that was
element was talking about was a violence
which exploded our into the country into
the cities what we see it doing now and
it not going to do it to the same
impression it's imploding within the
black communities all over the country
but it's the attempt still of black
people to find an expression for their
Nationals and it's in a sense
it added a dimension to the movement
which wasn't there in the earlier part
of the movement which is signified by
the demonstrations and the work we did
on voter registration well are you
optimistic or you pessimistic and do you
think the civil rights organizations in
the ACPs DLC well they no longer
relevant well no one would say that
they're no longer relevant what what we
what we are faced with is how how can we
adopt a strategy which is now
appropriate for our times but when I
think about the movement I think that
the the one main sort of thrust of the
movement went into policy that is the
energy which you identify in the early
part of movements in the early 60s went
over into politics and the event which
catches the the challenge the convention
in 1964 when the freedom Democratic
Party talyn's the Democratic Party to
throw out the regular party from
Mississippi and that sort of marked a in
a what by less than at the time called
the transition from protest the policy
and we've seen that sort of played out
over the last 25 years and of course the
the national symbol of that it does
eject right and the attempt to get the
Democratic Party to act in a way in
which it be it becomes a vehicle for the
continued realization of what we were
struggling for but when you label label
the the black movement black the
necessity for political voice as
nationalism
isn't is it the bread black nationalism
itself divisive okay
let me let me come back up on it if you
have you have the the attempt of black
people to find a political expression
and that has taken two forms one of
which is not really recognized as an
attempt for political expression right
this on the one hand the form in which
it permeates the sort of electoral
politics of this country so you have
people who are elected to offices in
your mayors your school committees
Congress and so forth and Jesse sort of
represents the pinnacle of that in the
attempt to become present right and
that's one movement which is it's an
expression trying to gain political
awareness and power there's another
expression which is symbolized by the
rebellion that is those rebellions at
their heart were an attempt to gain
political voice on the part of the inner
city population thanks it wasn't an
attempt it wasn't a strategy that could
work from the outside but from the point
of view of the people who are
participating in them that was their
attempt to get political warts right so
but you have to realize that uh that
none of those happen without one
ingredient it was a ghetto dweller and a
cop and it's kind of interesting if you
look at any one of those rebellions in
the african-american community all of
their the same ingredient I don't want
to get into food right or wrong but the
ingredients were it would never go back
before I got your job that will burn it
was always tipped off by a incidence of
pop and and and not one use against that
collected and so what we may you know it
the thing of being here today 20 years
ago this date a few hours from now
wonderful pink from assassinated order
this thing and now we say 60 years where
do we go where do we come from
well I think God when I talk about God
I'm not oh my god I need anybody's
validation is what we were really start
talking about because we've got some
serious problems now that the army that
your gun has a CI anything have you
thank you so also back into this fight
so we have some serious problems
now that have to be dealt with and I was
awed and could critic pick one who no
one who it would be you but I have to do
some power the see-cret ability but
information education is not power
mutters a solid information is power and
we talk about a free democratic society
and the closer I think being a prophet
is when you pick up what big Nixon says
if you elect me to present and I think
I'll take all the time on the streets
and you did but you did sum up has been
where you going
[Music]
which is old and when I heard through
the who's talking about math and I was
about that first
my younger brother Ron breakfast is the
world's record high school mom that was
another day First Baptist to get
sausages and we can - and you got Notre
Dame you made three days and I rushed
down here but I thought something might
be wrong with the school I'm going to
Baptist you know flunk math and algebra
all the way through grade school and
high school and make straight A's at
Notre Dame and he told me to when I got
in so that man is across I knew they
meant it
[Laughter]
[Music]
where do we go from here let me as I
listen general westmoreland talk the
tragedy is not the moving segment
because what bothers me more that has
kept the one that war he could have made
no more Nazi movies and we made in
America and I've never seen an American
movie make American make a German movie
with a short Nazi we're a wrinkled suit
on although Hitler was short they're all
blonde hair six four three with blue
eyes and a handsome so that means that
somebody underneath has a fascination
for that type of nonsense but what
bothers me about that one I was against
I mean I wasn't interested and if it
happened again I do against it but what
I'm for those youngsters that went over
that is back home not land up in PA
hospitals going unattended with the VA
budget in the last ten years then cut
sixty-two percent now that bothers me
that the people who can talk about why
we should have been it don't protect
them that the segment of the press that
went along with that bar don't protect
them if you don't believe me go to VA
hospitals and see how many third words
not third-world doctors you see there
that the American doctors wouldn't work
for them slave wages until some kind of
way when I sit back and I have ten
children and I'm in the peace movement
and if they had to get drafted I let
them go on one condition
you put my children where you put DuPont
boys then I know they would be safe
what if I didn't want somebody want to
deal with that get rich rich white folks
don't enter into the frontline the
munitions makers that makes billion
dollars off of that and to Gloria you
all should be happy over what happened
in Idaho there's a bunch of gun hole
god-fearing folks that believe the right
to a child and we're going to put
through a rigid abortion bill that's
going to lead to pass and then when
somebody says we embarked on Idaho
potatoes and has a charge between potato
or thoughts like that
and so finally I just want to treat in
my closing question thank you because if
there's anyone to change this whole
piece around yesterday you sitting it if
you're really willing to deal with
racism if you really wanted to deal with
sexes when I look at the crime report a
little rich a community two homicides
for the year five armed robberies fifty
break-ins and entries a hundred car
theft and six alleged rape they finally
get to that woman it's alleged and so I
say to you if you would use your
integrity and if you would leave here
understand that we don't have much time
and that you can make a difference kill
America's freedom problem without
harming black folks I wish I could tell
you is libel we've all black from
disappeared off this planet right now
come on one and all your wife America
will have the same problem so angry and
if all you white folk disappeared
we would have the same problem
and so I I say this if it's not white
folks it is not black folks and what is
it is the country that's our ethical
that's greedy that's unspiritual and
y'all can cover it up in all the games
you want until we willing to deal with
this part of it until we willing to
understand that white racist people
ain't nobody's problem
it's a white racist system which means
I'm part of it I have 10 black children
and my black children have never been
exposed to white folks in their life as
long as they're exposed to me and they
black mama they're going to grow up with
a white racist sexist mentality and if
we're not willing to deal with that then
you can kiss this country goodbye oh the
wall fell down in Berlin but they still
up around the Indian Reservation that
nobody seems to give a damn about a
black and South Africa's life expectancy
is 58 years of age but on the Indian
Reservation and Indians in this country
they life expectancy is 44 and so I say
to you the editors that you take the
power that you have of information or
the ruffball I made money on him with a
friend of mine and my family cause I bet
he would win that case against of white
friend of mine because of parts of
footballs integrity that I know he
wouldn't be up there in for Seward is
what's taught to bet on him and that's
what we need to do with the American
press and so I say that I'm out brings
over eight CIA agents died on that Pan
Am flight 103 and only one paper the
Pittsburgh Press reported it the CIA
rips off savings and loans across this
country and only the Houston post
reported it and y'all call ya'll self
reporters and think you got some special
gift from God y'all know what happened
on those damn assassinations and you
know damn good well you bet not
reporting you know rich white Cummings
is ripping off this country by the time
they wake up in the morning the time
they go to say it you know suck the CIA
is doing and if you report it the way
you record what [ __ ] is doing it
ghetto they would blow you out of your
house so I say to you and Jesse Jackson
been president for eight years and got
off the White House and going to Tokyo
and made a speech for two
million dollars in a language he
couldn't talk y'all would know he sold
in Japanese but anyway
[Applause]
who was who did you direct that question
I would like to discuss one thing like
general westmoreland you know who said
that the movies made a distortion of
Vietnam and so on well I'm not saying
I'm not much of a movie girl and you
didn't mention which ones they were but
I do read quite a lot and in spite of
this they had anything I probably read
as much as Jane Fonda but anyhow I've
just been reading this marvelous book at
least I thought it was I don't that
you've seen it a bright shining lie by
Neil Sheehan which is them about John
Paul's and have you read that book it
just came out too well I knew John Paul
Baran yes I know she exactly off also
the book and saying promote arises this
question there are a couple things in
there is a totally interesting piece of
reading I do recommend it you'll find
your own name in a great deal well I
have read those bought look yourself up
in the index I say I have read so far
yeah I have let myself open the Amanda
anyhow here's one one comment to my side
of interest and this is what she and
evaluation of the famous CBS libel suit
he said general Westmoreland over we had
an agreement not to discuss that he
didn't win the suit but he did not
either
he didn't either conspire to deceive the
president on the strengths of the enemy
as van said it was massive self delusion
have you comment about that I thought I
was interesting to have said massive
self though in other words he felt what
you weren't trying to deliberate in this
lead the president but that you yourself
was out
massive self delusion about virtual
strength ability of the enemy I've
talked to him number of times he did not
raise that question with me uh and
frankly it's not a rational question
directional comment in my opinion the
trust of the the CB s now infamous CB s
document I was a question of who you
would put in the border battle the
people that you wanted your soldiers to
destroy and I was very sensitive of the
Geneva Conventions I taught those at the
commander General Staff College and I
did everything I could to avoid civilian
casualties but she had never brought
this our subject up with me and if he
had I think I could have clarified the
math well apart then on the math of
civilian casualties you mean among the
death of these peasants and that sort of
thing well we this was a most of the war
that I suppose any country's ever fought
and one of the things that we tempted to
do and one of the things that all
commanders were indoctrinated with to go
to extremes to avoid civilian casualties
and how the extremes were such that a
lot of tackle commanders objected to him
incidentally his other point is
somewhere in the same book that the lack
of regard for the Vietnamese as the
people by the cycle of meaningless
violence that was general Westmoreland's
war of attrition military leaders and
civilian ly civilian leaders who
permitted generals to wage war as they
did made these massacres of whole
villages inevitable that says view well
when he discussed this with you not that
good no he has never brought this up to
me and they're not actually incorrect
every conceivable step was taken to
avoid civilian casualties every soldier
was given a card emphasizing that every
commander was given a card of the rule
to emphasize to protect the civilian
population that's what it was all about
well how do you account rollers
massacres and villages and death there
was no message the great masculine
villages there was the my love meal I
mean that was an isolated case which was
investigated in great detail and the
number of court martials resulted from
that general of leopards questions
indicated that the high degree of
entrance till now so many years later in
in details of the Vietnam War but as we
look ahead in 1990s and the turn of the
century what what effect has the entire
Vietnam War public opinion in this
country and so forth and the continuing
interest in discussion had upon our
ability to function in critical
situations as far as committing the
military it seems that the military
leadership is a little pardon upon gun
shy of public opinion these days and of
lending its support well I think you I
think you're quite correct Walter and I
think it's a spin-off of the trauma of
that not I think military is going to be
very very low to commit troops to the
battlefield unless they have assurance
that their efforts are going to be
supported by the American public and by
the protocol Authority now we just have
a case though and plant them always they
did panel and it turns out that the
number of civilian deaths in Panama
outnumbers the number of military deaths
by 61 well that's your statement I don't
want to kill the night I mean I want
advice on the threshold is based on the
official count well I I have no
knowledge of the details of that
operation I was not as long but I am
from a military standpoint it was a very
complex military plan which seemed to me
to be well executed how it was how in a
secret military operation do you
determine public support before the
operation takes place well I suppose a
you have better question a better
can answer that question than I am I
mean is not a function of the military
much of the political authority
generally really impressed with Heathrow
inspections to point that a point of
departure that Jack started and add my
voice to my concern about the
representation of 60s in the little film
clip that we saw because it seems to me
that that that's part of the continuing
problem that we in the media have our
distorted perception of our events and I
want to address the question that I have
out of that to Bob another thing that
struck me about that presentation was
the statement that the death of King was
the death of a concept you when both
leaders who always excuse the trappings
of leadership in fact that was part of
your legend the legendary Bob Moses whom
nobody ever sees but he works always in
evidence the the media always gravitated
to the most visible of the leaders and
in the absence of visible leaders they
created them and or anyone who happened
to be in a position to grab a microphone
the media gravitated to and then
therefore dubbed as a leader as we go
into the 90s with problems particularly
in disadvantaged minority communities
all over the country much greater than
they were it seems to me in the 60s
exacerbated in large part by drugs and
the crime and violence that that flows
from that in the absence of a visible
leadership how do you see these problems
being being addressed and how do you see
them getting any attention
in the media in the government and it's
not just a question of black leadership
I'm talking about black leadership
particularly but I'm talking about
national leadership as well and I'm
address really talking about leadership
and if these problems are going to need
the attention of leadership in order to
be addressed
who's that question address Bob
initially but anybody who wants to
respond to it yeah I liked it I'm not
I'm not sure I have a handle on the
question but I'd like to say how I what
I think is you know anthem of you know
[Music]
and that there were two traditions
within the civil rights movement there
was a tradition which is you could say
King Cymbeline where you have the
tradition of a person who is a national
leader who's a media person and who
addresses the nation in events which
have national importance we have a
number such into this Birmingham the
march on Washington Selma to Montgomery
so forth but there was another tradition
which in my mind is symbolized by prison
like Ella Baker and she never became a
media person and she acted in what we
call a tradition of organize that is she
was a person who worked as an organizer
and helped shape events in that capacity
and it's that tradition which I think
has a lot to say about the problems
which bays are selling in the city
but it's a tradition of the people
working in the community at a grassroots
level consciously in an organizing
tradition and building and the
grassroots mechanism and instruments
which can begin to deal with these
overwhelming problems than we have the
other product part of that how how does
that tradition gets translated into sort
of visible visibility nationwide or
across the nation the two traditions can
work together and I think part of what
we lack is an understanding of how that
happens the president the focus on
Freedom Summer as a national event which
impacted the country and had national
significance what is law is the
organizing work that went on for three
years prior to Freedom Summer without
which Freedom Summer could never have
happened and it's it's the it's the
molding of that kind of walk Latin words
are relevant talked about in terms of
the environmental thing I mean as he
taught my note to myself was this is a
part of an organizing tradition and one
of the things about organizing is you
start in your backyard right you start
at your doorstep you start with a
problem which is vocal in which you can
handle which has potential national
significance and it's because it has
such national significance that a lot of
people start with it in a lot of
backyard and then as the historical
forces sort of move then they come
together you can get something like
Earth Day which has a national impact
right and you saw the same thing
happening in the freedom in the in the
moon
I guess my question is are you seeing
this happening in the in these minority
communities today because as you look at
the incident I was talking to
congressman flake on the plane going
down here today and he was talking about
the number of border babies in these
hospitals that are just languishing
there with no you know no hope of any
way to sim sim the number of these
children being born to mothers addicted
to crack all of these problems that seem
so relentless and seem to be getting
even worse who who who is dealing with
those problems and do you see that kind
of movement that you're describing
impacting on them yeah well you have
against the clearest case of a group of
people working on this kind of problem
is the Children's Defense Fund and mine
realm but as there you have a case of
picking out the piece of the problem I'm
dealing with
intercity young people and working first
at local levels and getting a lot of
people working on that piece of the
problem and as we saw just recently
coming out with a nation a national
response now we hope that bush is one of
you know flaws that bill and and make it
help make it happen and he won't play
the fool and veto it but there you have
a case where someone is working I mean
it's absolutely critical if you're going
to get at these problems in in a city
that you begin very specific right with
specific pieces of it and you begin to
fashion out remedies for specific pieces
of I suppose I what you call good Bob
bottom line Jackson got a chance okay
I'm not a blogger
I thought you can ask more if we get
into this I thought oh sorry it takes me
a plenty including sixties was a lot of
energy was poured into social change by
coming to Washington and asking for
programs by you know we have a Great
Society programs enacted under Lyndon
Johnson in the early salad days so then
we have the marches on Washington
through the civil rights movement and
what's been so striking about the
presentations today is the talk is
turned to empowerment of individuals
turning away from Washington turning to
lay - trying to create things within
neighborhoods trying to create things
among people and that is Washington
forces are you no longer looking to
washing because you don't think they
have the answers or you think it's
becoming irrelevant just in Canada lolly
in your wheel well the last two
presidents who could come to Washington
and I'll change the focus the energy
when individuals know and then this
understanding of the movement I mean we
work for years in Mississippi without
turning the Washington marching on
Washington we were working and
organizing our people in Mississippi and
under the same idea of empowerment right
now when they came when they got
organized to a point that they
themselves were ready to put the
question to the specific country then
they turn to a national institution say
the Democratic Party right and put the
question to the Democratic Party what
are you folks want to do about your part
in this problem right and I think
there's going to always be this back and
forth right but well I would reflect
this agreement process and name
something I'm feeling on the off chance
that maybe anybody else is feeling this
too it feels like there's a dynamic
going on here that so often goes on
between the media and a movement which
is the following
Jack ask a question with all goodwill
which in the nature of the question
I think caused us all to see doom
disaster diminished almost no future the
movement isn't there and so on then Bob
has to build up psychically you know but
look I'm
everything that's gone into the
electoral system everything that's gone
on to other kinds of demonstrations I
mean to build up again what is in fact
there right then Charlayne asks a
question which is sort of there is no
leadership
whereas leadership which again shrimp
shrinks our imagination of the
leadership then we come back I'm not
doing that's the question I ask I ask
well is a changing nature of leadership
right members and are we as media
because I sort of sit on both sides of
this event
sometimes a weird media focusing on the
wrong issue I think I do I think that
there's an answer to that and that is
that it would be very helpful if if we
went back to our 60s methods of briefing
editorial boards and gone and gave you a
list of more lists of people because
you're under tight time deadlines and
you need people to call on specific
issues and so on and what's going on and
a greater list of people who can be
turned to as folks people and you know
who are there who are empowering them
but I mean the same dynamic happens
again when Dave said but in the past it
was all it was coming to Washington now
that's gone away in the fact in the past
that wasn't all going to Washington it
was empowerment it always has been
community empowerment but I mean it was
both things as I want to get that now
but what I'm not I'm not talking about
the substance so much here as I am
talking about the enormous psychic
energy it takes to build up reality
again after the negative question about
the civil rights is said
feminism is said because it's a question
not I mean it's in all goodwill but it's
a question of interpretation and
identification for the president of
course not no absolutely not daughter I
think it may be alive but it's lost the
political handle and I think Dave is on
to something that's very realistic that
some of these movements have been on the
wrong political horse
and over a period of twenty years they
had simply lost out in the political
process a representation of the black
representation politically in this
country now these RVs but what locally
is the point I mean that's where you
know revolutions are not built from the
top down like houses they're built from
the bottom up we also met that when
newspapers you when anyone feel the
movement if use the newspaper then one
of the things is you come to Washington
where the presses and and the presents
are interested and what you did in
Mississippi three years ago they
interested in that system then you have
two different forces one plan for the
press the other one is empowering people
which whatever the fact is the press is
not all in Washington and there are a
lot of folks out here who know how their
folks at home feel about these meetings
I live way out in the boondocks and
people could care less out there about
the civil rights movement or the women's
movement in the main I live in a very
Hispanic area where political concerns
are very fractionalized and very few
black people and very few militant
feminists I think I make you know I know
we're are very wrong feminist groups
which you don't recognize in feminist
groups because they don't look like
white militants or militant I mean we
don't even have a helicopter much less
you know but I mean
they don't know they don't look like the
protection of feminist groups it's very
hard for a Hispanic feminist woman to be
identified as a feminist because people
think that by definition feminists are
not Hispanic that's what I'm talking
about the difference in perception is
probably history is called colors know
what that kind of stuff
well that's their problem that's another
element in this whole thing but they're
they're very intensive it is they're big
groups and benefit this this country has
a rather low center of gravity these
days where these things are concerned
and and it used to be that you came to
Washington I think that's correct
take Kent State there was an immediate
massive pilgrimage to Washington's
reaction to Gallaudet are we ignoring
the abortion demonstrations the biggest
demonstrations in you know recent years
that all came to Washington to me when
it's necessary to come to Washington we
tell them well the most isolated things
I've heard said you today is what other
experts said about the young students in
college being interested in public
service because that had not been - I
think in the dependi 80s or in the 70
and I'll tell you something I've been in
Washington for 20 years I had never seen
such despair as I see in Washington
today on Capitol Hill among the
Democrats among a lot of Republicans do
not think that President Bush display
all this popularity outside the Beltway
that he is not providing any sort of
leadership to grapple with the prestige
problem 20 years ago I was evident you
heard Jimmy Carter talk about malaise he
didn't really say malaise the press even
pick up a word and suddenly but
nevertheless he did say that the country
seemed to be losing this period right
now I mean I can tell you talk about
anybody else coming Washington we have
the other day we had 30 members of the
executive committee of the LA Chamber of
Commerce in our Bureau and if anybody
all be happy if those guys out in LA
where the pork is now have to exceed the
New York Post for the first time for the
economy offensively I asked them the
same question all 30 members of their
spouse and 60 people I said do you think
anybody in Washington is addressing the
problems of this country in Washington
either at the White House in Congress
not a one
Jaqueline think there are a lot of
Democrats you put it all of them Bush it
no you're doing what I don't think
that's a fully after straight about
what's going on here she's not exactly
the the fact is there are a lot of
Democrats also in this town who no
longer have taste and the kind of
solutions that we pursue during the 60s
for they don't want encouraged to admit
it they have the faith in them that's
right and frankly neither party at this
point has much of a program agenda that
they really believe in they're all
feeling very well with the Democrats
split over this child care bill Marian
Wright Edelman in fact in the end lost
out this is not for child care bill any
longer it's a child care bill which is
much closer to what conservatives
believe because the Democrats no longer
had faith in those kind of solutions and
that's what I was trying to argue it's
usually what Democrats are coming to
believe in you've got to empower
individuals and a party is coming around
a bit Lori I really do Democrats as well
as Republicans I mean I don't think
anybody believes in this town that
either side is is providing any sort of
real leadership okay and I'd like to
come back in there about because there's
a distinction between the Democratic
Party and its beliefs even those
believes in the sixties that they had
and the movement because the movement
brought the question of empowerment to
the Democratic Party most graphically
again with freedom Democrats from
Mississippi here on your sharecropper
who have empowered themselves in the
political process right on the job so to
speak are you ready and able to
incorporate them into the Democratic
Party and the response in essence was no
they have to be trained in the
university they have to go through the
credentialing process that's accepted in
this country so that in order to become
part of that process and what that was
one of the great losses right in terms
of the movement in this country having
an answer to the problems which later
erupted as a rebellion because that
event
called a political way to handle what
was happening in the city let me get
back to Charlotte Phoebus I think
there's another thing that's happening
around the leadership question and the
visibility and that's the technology the
technology and the TV was cutting it to
teeth in the sixties what you have is
two national channels and then ABC right
and so it only had these three vehicles
to project leadership groups you've got
a whole other technology out in there
with all these cable channels and so
forth
you've got people sitting watching on
the screen they're local leaders right
and the technology is driving the shift
from having the need to have one or two
people who represent everybody to the
ability to have a lot of people right
through the technology who can have
access and it's it's the same kind of
it's driving also this ship for the
decentralization of everything you mean
the computer is a huge port for the
central defensive addiction that we
think we you know the hope of stance of
Detectives all of it and then that's the
book you see what I mean but other than
who I do is not democracy at all nothing
on a toilet actually there was nothing
very different cameras all the other
vibrant voice and he'll thing being
Jesse Jackson and then he seems to me to
be portrayed by the Democrats and
refining things so they are there is no
very optimistic business and unless you
know your idea these grassroots
neighborhoods a really good time seems
as we move into the 90 that is one of
the key issues is is the education of
the American public politically
well as in all the other aspects of
socially and and in the mathematics of
your rodent arrest together with the
lack of education American public we all
know the educational system has failed
up to now as great as the leadership has
been at the top of other aspirations and
people that great character basically
it's failed and we're raising
functionally illiterate in the too much
to larger degree for any civilized
nation at the same time we have changed
our means of information communication
to this short form television terribly
short form television when you Gloria
you Bob others talk about about
discussing the broader movement the the
underlying forces behind any particular
demonstration rather which we should be
discussing the only place you're going
to find it is in a good newspaper
you're not very likely to find very much
of it on the medium that most people are
using as their principal source of
information that's television and we've
got to find some way it seems to me
besides working on the basic educational
principles to someone or rather
communicate with that mass of persons up
there many of them don't have an
adequate of education even to read their
newspapers and who are ten depending
entirely on television to get these more
subtle problems out to them so they can
participate in the democracy is usage as
fob they are not being able to today and
I don't think it's just in science
education and mathematics although
that's terribly important one of the
major problems we've got today it seems
to me is indeed in the high-tech society
we as we that become a man out there
this certainly includes me and I think
it would include a lot of you out there
I don't know enough about what's going
on in our atomic plants I don't know
enough about what's going on in the food
additives I don't know what not what's
going on in pesticides I don't have the
technical knowledge for that I've got to
depend upon of an autocracy an oligarchy
of scientists a handful of people are
advising Congress a handful of people
were advising the President and they're
making the decisions from in whether I
live or die
whether my children live or die somehow
we've got to find a way to get democracy
back in our hands and it can only be
done by education and information and
we're all a part of that I think as a
matter of fact that we've just about to
come to us the end of our discussion
period we've run over a little bit but
we took over a little late I want to
thank all of you for participating in
this discussion today
[Applause]